Gregg what's the first time we got some
more news in the caravan industry a new
za raba and caravan the caravan is back
a new new care of a new caravan of
migrants is forming in Honduras and you
know what they left today as we're
taping on Tuesday a historic day a new
caravan of migrants going up through
Honduras going to Mexico and heading
into the USA yeah for the care if you're
a caravan this is like your combine you
know it's getting from Honduras to
across the border I think it's more like
getting just to the border and then once
you're there depending on you know what
your vertical is they let you they let
you in uh you know Greg and I talked
about this last night the NFL it's a
copycat league yeah you know I mean they
saw the last caravan come in and they
were like we need more caravans you know
we need more caravans and I think that
caravans could start their own league
kind of like the AFL and then in a
couple of seasons it would be the carrot
whoever like the champion of the
caravans maybe it's this one maybe it's
care about like the AFL like when they
had the leverage to force the NFL to
merge that's how the NFL came to be a
little history lesson here for tempo see
you know they had the leverage because
they were making so much money
the caravan in a few years could be in
that situation and there are thousands
of people in these caravans one of
them's got to be a Joe Namath type you
know I mean who could just like
guarantee a win and then put it over the
top I think I think I'm pretty pumped I
think it's like it because it's a
copycat league it's like the methods
that the first caravan were bringing I
think are gonna go throughout the league
the West Coast principle is kind of the
air it out principles like we're gonna
be aggressive and go for it like we're
not kicking on fourth down we're gonna
go caravan yeah okay it's like the
caravan is the new West Coast offense
you know I mean everyone's gonna be
trying to gain an advantage by gleaming
off the caravan I think you have to
worry though about just kind of getting
like the last remnants of this caravan
phase it's like how everyone in the NFL
is just like hiring someone that knows
Sean McVeigh or worked with Sean McVeigh
the Rams coach it's like you have to be
worried if you're the Honduras Caravan
you're not really gonna stack up to the
original I just kind of like a copycat
mmm-hmm I think they're gonna learn from
the mistakes of the first caravan and
they're going to they're
handle the teargas better for sure like
they know it's coming I think it's gonna
be good I can't wait until Maddon comes
out next year yeah Maddon caravanning
you can play different members of the
caravan trying to get across the border
that would be the best game like
different members of the caravan are
like really upset with their mat and
score like they're like no way I
shouldn't be a 79 and strength like I
could carry way more than that yeah and
I think the the caravan will be like the
first team to have jerseys that had
three digits on them didn't because
there's so many you couldn't just have
two digits they'd be like oh right oh
yeah like oh he's number four thousand
twenty four mm-hmm yeah exactly what's
the next headline
Clemson won the national championship
just a week ago it felt like and they
were already celebrating the title at
the White House with old President Trump
who welcomed them with a lot of
hamburgers a lot of fast food you know
there because of the government shutdown
not all the employees are there so he
said he paid it paid out of his own
pocket to hook them up with some
McDonald's and Wendy's and Burger King
this is the saddest trashy I've
ever heard in my life I don't know how
you spell like people are spinning this
is like oh it was like a good thing
these players I mean they just won this
what like a week ago I feel like they
just went from the game White House ever
I might be wrong but I think I mean
totally it's a huge PR move ESPN I like
to call out networks ESPN is totally in
the tank for Trump and that their
headline of the article is players cheer
for fast food at the White House please
no one walked in i heard someone like
say quote was like I thought they were
joking when they said this and they walk
in and see all this see like a stack of
fillet a fish on a silver tray and I
don't believe to Trump paid for it
himself also but that doesn't make it
better
he literally owns you know a hotel down
the street that has a catering company
like saying that all I could you know
fork out was 300 fillet of fishes is
does that make you look better no and
where's Milania
could you imagine it
mama tried to give everyone fast food
athletes fast food you want what uh what
Michelle Obama would have done she would
have buried herself in the garden all
right yeah I can't believe anyone let
this happen we thought it was a good
look it is completely insane he imagined
winning and like when Clemson was here
Cole guy said it was the bet it's
freezing cold that's the best friend you
can't have cold if they requested fast
food and they were like you want fast
food here you go that would have been
cool and they would have kept it hot or
whatever no way that had been sitting
out there for hours at least and last
year when they went one of the Clemson
players said they served barbecue and
was the best meal he'd had all year
imagine thinking you're about to get the
best meal you've had all year and then
you walk into that right someone said
like you know you have to be awfully
racist to buy that much fast food and
not have like a spicy chicken sandwich I
don't know yeah I don't know I don't
know about that I would say I would
believe there's some racism going on but
it is it's repulsive like Alabama should
have gotten fast food like cold fast
food right like Clemson
it'll probably one Nick I can imagine
Nick Saban being like congratulations on
your season this is what number like
second place gets and then they stuck he
does a big reveal and it's bunch of cold
fast food and they're just like cry
themselves to sleep and what I feel like
when the teams visit the White House I
was just seeing like out in the front
steps doing the photo-op you know I mean
I throw him a football or whatever and
they they give a little speech I never
even heard there was like a big meal
then why is this whole story just about
what he fed them I don't know he really
he says that this is the food that he
likes he couldn't pick a favorite that
part I believe Trump is like the single
dad who has no idea what he's doing in
like last minute kind of just like oh I
better buy $200 for the fast food on the
way there I think this is more
calculated I think it's more I think
they thought like oh like the people who
support us like the fact that we're that
we're doing fast food the things that
they eat and and that that all these
government workers who haven't been paid
in a month have had to eat off the
dollar menu and no Sonic
I have Wendy's Burger King Donald's no
Sonic little Popeyes would have been
nice
they had friend
Frye's in presidential cups it's the
saddest trashiest I've ever heard
of in my life I don't even have a joke
about it I think it's calculated to like
make us stop talking you know about the
big dump that the president's taken all
over America and it worked it's on it's
made the the heights of broadcasting the
jessalyn that can Rosenthal vanity
project our next story is from something
for the ladies is next door is comes
from the world of the WWE a lot of
wrestlers really the whole wrestling
community is in an uproar after a
wrestler Priscilla Kelly took a tampon
out during a match and shoved it down an
opponent's throat yeah this is hilarious
to me that the wrestlers are upset that
this is like damaging the good name of
professional wrestling
I understand listen I've got a
tremendous amount of respect for
professional wrestlers I know what they
do is physically demanding and I know
the wrestling is fake but what they do
is is an actual sport I do believe that
they are real athletes this couldn't be
more fake someone taking out a tampon
and putting it down her opponent it
wasn't like the opponent was passed out
like the opponent's awake being like oh
no it lets her shove a tampon down the
throat it was not a real tampon was not
even a I've seen that because why would
they do that
what well why not dip a tampon and
ketchup and then do it and it's okay
like players cut themselves there's no
way she was like hey to sell this and
this was like this it wasn't a televised
event it was like a bar show and and
someone someone took a video of it WWE
Hall of Famer Jim Ross called it
embarrassing deaq legend Road Dogg Jesse
James said this is the stuff is some
reason why this is the reason why people
despise our industry it's got nothing to
do with taking life seriously it's about
dignity and personal pride she obviously
have has none where do these wrestlers
come off and certain like they they
literally are the most like WWE has been
one of the most racist like sexist
organizations they're always doing stuff
like you know hitting each other over
the head with with uh with the chair and
I try to you trust I've just said state
like they
a thing where you staple each other's
head like that's somehow better yeah I
like that they're mad at the girl who
took her tampon out and put it down the
girl's throat but no one says anything
the girl who lets someone put a tampon
down their throat I thought that would
be the more undignified thing I assumed
when I read this story that Jim Ross and
all the ones getting mad were like sort
of part of the bit like you know how in
wrestling it's like you have to act like
the bad guys being bad but they they
truly seem like they are offended get
over yourselves Greg it gets even worse
for women in this next headline on
Saturday Sarah Thomas made history by
becoming the first woman to officiate an
NFL postseason game officiating a
postseason game is like for a woman is
like breaking the glass basement yeah
like how is this getting worse for a
woman it's cool that because being a
referee is like one of the worst jobs
ever like I'm glad they're there women
referees if you wanted to put make all
referees female I'd be down with that
but why would she want this job it ain't
a referee it's the worst job I think in
the NFL by far
she's Sarah Thomas seems to do a great
job she's been doing it for a few years
this was her first playoff date
game but yeah there is something kind of
funny about like congratulations for
being the first person to hold this
incredibly difficult job that doesn't
have benefits in which 70,000 people
basically hate you every weekend yeah
the fact that she's doing it for years
and I have not heard anything about her
means that she's awesome at this you
know I mean cuz people would love to
trash a female rapper like if they do in
the NBA I feel like they're like they
were like she shouldn't be here and they
were wrong but this is a bad job I would
rather have a tampon stuff down my
throat
then then referee in the NFL
[Music]
you